Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Eighteen: health and the health service.
Health is one of the areas that voters think is most important of all.
The health service is also the area, only surpassed by transfer incomes, that the public sector spends most money on in Denmark.
In 2025 the health service made up 9.4 percent of Denmark's total economy, and the expenses have grown quickly in recent decades.
The reason for this increase is partly that there are more elderly people, but the increase is especially due to technology constantly giving more and better, but also more expensive, possibilities for treating diseases.
Health in a historical perspective.
Some way into the 1800s, life expectancy in the population was only about 40 years, and a large part of the population died already as children.
Since then public health has improved significantly.
The Danish population now lives much longer.
Life expectancy is, in 2024 to 2025, 83.9 years for women and 80.3 years for men.
Another result of the improved health is that the population has become much taller.
The average height has since the middle of the 1800s grown from about 165 centimetres for men and 155 centimetres for women to 180 centimetres for men and 167 centimetres for women.
The improved health is due to a number of different factors, which really began in the 1800s.
First, much more food can be produced.
That means everyone has enough to eat and can thereby also better resist diseases.
Second, medical science has developed considerably: science knows much more about bacteria, viruses and other things that make us ill, and thus also about how diseases can be prevented and treated.
Third, hygiene has improved with, for example, underground sewers, running drinking water, toilets and healthier homes.
There is also greater general knowledge in the population about how important good hygiene is for avoiding diseases.
Fourth, a health service has been built up where all citizens have access to go to a doctor and to hospital.
Copenhagen's Municipal Hospital, Københavns Kommunehospital, built 1858 to 63, was one of Denmark's first "modern" hospitals.
In the last half of the 1800s and the beginning of the 1900s, over 100 hospitals were built in Denmark.
From 1893 the state gave grants to sick funds, sygekasser, which were insurance schemes in relation to illness: if you paid a fixed contribution to the sick fund, you could in return get your expenses covered when you were at, for example, a general practitioner.
The sick funds existed until 1973, when they were replaced by an entirely public system: the public health insurance, den offentlige sygesikring.
Changes in the disease picture.
The social development that has made us much richer in a few generations has not only given us the means for better treatment and got rid of many of the diseases that come with malnutrition.
At the same time it has given us the means to eat much more, fatty and sugary, food, and to smoke tobacco and drink more alcohol.
This has led to a big growth in Denmark, as in many other countries, in the number of so-called lifestyle diseases, livsstilssygdomme, that is diseases you have an increased risk of getting because of the way you live.
It can for example be diseases such as cancer, cardiovascular diseases, diabetes and COPD.
The changed way of living is among other things also reflected in the share of citizens who are severely overweight having risen from 5 to 6 percent in 1987 to 19 percent in 2023.
Lifestyle diseases are also decisive for the fact that, even though the majority of the health service is free, there is still "social inequality in health".
Because the unhealthy way of living is to a great extent connected with a number of social conditions, not least level of education.
There are thus more people with short education who smoke, eat unhealthily or exercise little or not at all.
Conversely there are slightly more people with long education, especially among people over 65, who drink a lot of alcohol.
But overall people with short education have greater risk of getting a number of diseases and dying relatively early than people with long education.
Unskilled workers live, for example, on average five to seven years shorter than academics.
A number of laws have been passed that are to get more people to live healthier.
For example you must be 16 years old to buy beer in the shops, with an alcohol content of between 1.2 and 6 percent, and 18 years to buy cigarettes, strong beer, wine and strong spirits, with an alcohol content of 6.6 percent and above.
In nightlife zones you must also be 18 years old to buy alcohol after 10 pm.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
What was life expectancy for women in 2019 to 2020?
Option A: 78 to 79 years.
Option B: 83 to 84 years.
Option C: 88 to 89 years.
[DA] Hvad var middel-levetiden for kvinder i 2019-2020?  A: 78-79 år  |  B: 83-84 år  |  C: 88-89 år
The answer is B: 83 to 84 years.
It appeared in the November 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: 83-84 år
Question 2.
How long was life expectancy for men in 2020 to 2021?
Option A: About 73 years.
Option B: About 80 years.
Option C: About 87 years.
[DA] Hvor lang var middellevetiden for mænd i 2020-2021?  A: Cirka 73 år  |  B: Cirka 80 år  |  C: Cirka 87 år
The answer is B: About 80 years.
It appeared in the November 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Cirka 80 år
Question 3.
How old must you be to buy cigarettes in Denmark?
Option A: At least 16 years.
Option B: At least 18 years.
Option C: At least 21 years.
[DA] Hvor gammel skal man være for at købe cigaretter i Danmark?  A: Mindst 16 år  |  B: Mindst 18 år  |  C: Mindst 21 år
The answer is B: At least 18 years.
It appeared in the November 2021, May 2024 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Mindst 18 år
Question 4.
How old must you at least be to buy strong spirits?
Option A: 15 years.
Option B: 18 years.
Option C: 21 years.
[DA] Hvor gammel skal man mindst være for at købe stærk spiritus?  A: 15 år  |  B: 18 år  |  C: 21 år
The answer is B: 18 years.
It appeared in the May 2023 and November 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: 18 år
That's the end of Part One of Episode 18.
In Part Two, we continue with smoking, mental health and the health service.
See you there.